it's difficult to avoid startups in Tel
Aviv this is just one floor of one
building and it's absolutely bursting
with them you've got round Forest meme
Global Media Group get you another weird
and wonderfully named startups but one
company you wouldn't expect to find here
is Coca-Cola
we've started a program called the
bridge it's about helping young startups
in Israel and eventually around the
world learn how to commercialize their
products so that we can take advantage
of them and use them to help us with our
business cook selected 10 startups for
its pilot program one of them is screamo
express it and break the glass screen
will create mobile to screen interactive
experiences in this example you can see
a girl that choosing the best outfit
that she likes using her mobile and put
it on a big billboard and then
immediately receive the 20 off discount
on this outfit that this is kind of a
call to action to get into the stores
from the street and get this outfit in
the Next Room we find we find which has
developed a tracking bracelet for use in
theme parks and Resorts so our
technology allows you to use the already
existing Wi-Fi in order to communicate
back and forth to send messages to don't
wait in line because we can measure how
many people stand we can pinpoint you
and say come here and buy a Coke as well
as office space startups get video
conference advice from Coca-Cola
Executives in Atlanta and a chance to
partner with a company for their launch
for some the synergies are clear Dobby's
software could help your phone talk to
one of Coke's 15 million vending
machines for others like canine social
network Hachiko you need to think
outside the can watching where the dogs
go we know where the humans go and we'll
be able to understand the what we call
geofencing or the proximity of where
they are to opportunities to quench
their thirst and hydrate cook doesn't
take stakes in the startups but by
mentoring them it gets Early Access to
their technology and prevents the
competition from getting there first